good afternoon I'm marshal of it as
Farnum introduced and I want to welcome
everyone to our first symposium of the
day on Pittsburgh as a living lab I'll
turn it over to the panelists and ask
each of them to introduce themselves so
we can get right into the work that's so
exciting we'll hear about today so hello
everybody I'm Anthony Roe from the
electrical and computer engineering
department and I'm the director of the
conex Research Center which is working
on looking at future distributed
computing system design specifically for
helping smart cities and connected
communities good afternoon I'm Ilana
Bosch I am Caine Ella gates professor of
ethics and computational technologies in
the robotics Institute and I'm at the
create lab and create stands for
community robotics education and
technology empowerment hi I'm Mary Lewis
Scott I'm an architect and an educator
I'm a studio professor and associate
head of the school of architecture in
CMU and I'm going to talk about a
project that I've been co-directing
called night-owl Baker's and I'm working
with Christian Hughes who is faculty in
the School of Design
hi I'm West peg den I'm an associate
professor in the math department and one
area of my research is using mathematics
to rigorously identify gerrymandered
political districting that is to
distinguish dish things which have been
intentionally drawn with partisan bias
from those which have some partisan bias
which just arises naturally from the
political geography of the state and I'm
Marcia Levitt I'm going to focus on my
role directing the Eberly Center which
is Carnegie Mellon's teaching an EdTech
Center where we're working with
colleagues across campus to transform
learning transform teaching with machine
learning in fact I'll start off and say
that this is a living laboratory we have
actually right down the hallway at the
end of the hall we have a new center
technology enhanced learning center
where we have a living laboratory in the
form of two modern classrooms now if you
should walk down the hall later this
afternoon
and
look at those classrooms you'll see that
they are pretty fancy they have modern
flexible furniture that makes it easy to
move around and switch from a lecture
mode to small group interaction to
collaborative learning in mere moments
they have interactive displays on the
walls and plenty of whiteboards I really
really went a little crazy on the
whiteboards but what most visitors see
when they walk into the room are the
features I just mentioned and none of
those are what make them so special and
exciting to me you have to look up when
you get to these classrooms and see that
what we have in this ceiling is a pipe
grid onto which cameras microphones and
other sensors can be placed so that we
can actually study the learning and
teaching that's going on here at
Carnegie Mellon so I like to think of
them as instrumented classrooms instead
of when I was a graduate student
studying learning in the psychology
laboratory which is not real learning in
real classrooms we're actually bringing
that instrumentation to actual Carnegie
Mellon classes and in fact we have
several that are being taught there this
semester one thing that's really
exciting about this to me is every day I
see Carnegie Mellon faculty member
working with my colleagues at the Eberly
Center transforming teaching identifying
new ways to create learning experiences
for their students and Farnam said in
his remarks this morning that we really
are innovating and transforming higher
education innovation is great but
sometimes we have to recognize that our
innovations may or may not work so the
idea of these instrumented classrooms is
to really promote educational innovation
with iteration so that we can ask our
colleagues to dream their biggest dreams
try it out and then we'll help them work
with them collect data on how students
are learning how they're engaged how
they're transferring what they learned
and what behaviors in the classroom and
outside are actually contributing to the
best for our students and the data that
we're collecting in these living labs is
a key part of that but that's a focus on
campus my colleagues and I also are
making a big impact in the
unity so maybe Anthony you'd like to
talk about that sure thanks thanks
Marcia so a lot of the work that I do is
insert smart and connected communities
and one of the key challenges to
enabling smart and connected communities
is making sure that we have easy to use
accessible and secure access to sensors
and wireless connectivity pervasively
across an environment and so there's one
thing to be said about designing a
single sensor that you can build it does
one particular purpose but it's a
totally different beast to actually have
thousands of these sensors that you
distribute across the city that have to
collect data at scale that push this
information back to analytics this
basically requires expertise in hardware
design wireless communication data
storage analytics driven by AI and
machine learning these are all things
that you find readily available on CMU's
campus and so this is an absolutely
fantastic environment to be working on
that so one of the projects that I've
been working on is deploying low cost
low-power wide-area sensor networks
across the community so actually if you
go back to the previous slide if you can
this is a picture where we've deployed a
bunch of different gateways that sit on
top of buildings on campus and the idea
is unlike wireless networks like Wi-Fi
in a building where you need hundreds of
them to cover a building one of these
devices actually covers a couple of city
blocks and instead of supporting you
know high data rate things like cell
phones they're designed for these
low-power IOT devices that basically
sense information from the environment
and then can push a very low data rate
back to a central thing so the idea is
that we can use these for a whole bunch
of different types of applications so
one of the applications picture in the
next slide is looking at predictive and
preventative maintenance as well as
monitoring of infrastructure around the
city so this is actually a picture of
the Liberty bridges which a year ago
actually caught on fire and so the
question is how can we actually tell if
these bridge structures are safe anymore
and so the way people typically do that
is they go up and they measure specific
points on the bridge and they take spot
samples and they try to estimate the
structural integrity
so what some
students assume you are able to do is
actually create sensors that can do this
continuously over long periods of time
that are very easy to install and they
can communicate back using this wireless
infrastructure we created another
example of a project that I've been
closely collaborating with professor
Mario Burgess in the civil engineering
department so we can go to the next
slide is actually on tracking and
monitoring the flow of people in and out
of spaces on campus and so the idea here
is if we can estimate where people are
moving and how they're utilizing the
space we can do things like adjust the
heating and cooling to save energy we
can increase comfort we can make sure
that we're utilizing resources another
example of a projects that I've been
working on again with Mario is actually
on retrofitting old-fashioned electric
heaters that you might find in
commercial spaces around campus as well
as in residential areas where we can
make them smarter so they can actually
act as a ballast for the smart grid and
again all of this is because we're able
to tie physical information to sensors
collect that information process it the
last project that I want to talk about
which is kind of new to the group in the
center that I'm running is actually on
doing hyper precise indoor localization
in spaces so being able to very
precisely track assets and phones in the
same way GPS does outside but only
inside buildings and we're working on a
project actually now with the Pittsburgh
Science Center where we can accurately
track the phone enough that we can
project digital content in fixed place
in the environment so this is called
mobile augmented reality and the idea
here is that we could have for example a
kids and parents having a tour around a
museum or a facility or you could
imagine you know the slightly less
glamorous version of this would be
looking at facility maintenance
information in a machine room or a
mechanical room on campus so lots of
really interesting activity that we
think can leverage all of this highly
available communication and sensory
information and I actually know that ela
has also been working a fair bit on
sensing and sensor processing so maybe
I'll turn it over to him Thank You
Anthony
fantastic so I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about empowerment and tell
you a story of empowerment but to start
we live in an age of data and
information and this parts really
important information typically is part
of
power negotiation it's part of how one
group of people derives power against
others and creates subaltern groups and
the recognition that you can use
information to control has been around
for ages here is Jeremy Bentham's
panopticon a word that has stuck with us
till now and this is from 240 years ago
the idea of a prison in which the center
cell where the guards are can view any
cell where the prisoners are and the
prisoners don't where they're being
watched so what happens is the notion is
that surveillance and information itself
changes the rates at which people behave
and so people actually behave better
because of that
and we were right down for the next lab
already this slide is actually remarking
on the fact that in fact this idea of
surveillance changing human behavior is
of course rife around us we have
surveillance cameras all over cities
like London and even Pittsburgh some 300
400 thousand now in most of the major
cities around the world at least and it
has had a big impact on people but the
power structures behind those have been
that those in power those with money and
influence have used these systems to
control what the creator has done in
asking ask the question can we use
information to empower individual
community members and community action
groups in such a way that they can make
the world a better place
and that's really what I want to talk to
you about and there's one particular
issue in which I'm going to give you my
narrative about Pittsburgh which is air
pollution and this next picture is
something that you're all familiar with
it's the disaster we have around the
world from industrialization of air
pollution which causes early death it
causes cardiovascular disease and asthma
everywhere but it causes these very same
things in Pittsburgh and so we can treat
Pittsburgh as a local laboratory to
think about power and the ways in which
we can invert data and power
relationships so this next picture is
what you'd like Pittsburgh to look like
and it does look like this about 80 days
a year but what it looks like the rest
of the time is the next picture and the
difference between those is stark and
that's why we have some city schools
that have the highest asthma rates in
the entire state of Pennsylvania even
though we're much smaller than
Philadelphia which is really depressing
so what we did with surveillance here is
return the question of information
topsy-turvy by empowering local
community advocacy groups to own in
information and to become privileged
through information so using Carnegie
Mellon create lab technologies we
created networks of cameras that could
see the individual smoke go ahead Frank
in this next picture we used computer
vision algorithms to have cameras
installed by citizenry into their attics
that actually detected every illegal
smoke plume in the city and detected and
recorded those and then we could
enumerate those together you can go to
the next one and created about a
thousand five hundred of these per week
a thousand five hundred eleven z' in the
coke factory in Chenango and Neville
island that the community created that
the community owned and then the
community created with us a website on
the next slide we're on this website
it's put together not only the illegal
plumes with visual evidence that the
community owned but their own stories
about asthma their own stories about
emergency room entries and wind
direction and federal government sensors
on air quality and their own locally
installed air quality sensors from the
create lab so all together the website
created a living document with so much
compelling visual evidence that the
coordinator for the EPA was compelled to
come out here and listen to the
community talk about the health effects
they have because of the local cook
processing plant and I'm gonna leave the
punchline for my next part so while you
think about where this all went and what
impact it had I'm happy to introduce
Mary Lou has done who's one of my heroes
because she's been doing really careful
work on community Co participatory
design with technology thanks it has
been a leading light and a real example
to me on how you can activate a
community and give a community some
empowerment from the ground up so the
work that I've been doing with Kristen
Hughes really is a collaborative effort
which spreads beyond the CMU
collaborations right into the ecosystem
of Pittsburgh and I think what we have
to you know give incredible thanks to
the foundations that have very slowly
supported small initiatives that we've
been making over several years the Heinz
Endowment gave us a seed fund to plant
seeds we did a summer of growing on
vertical surfaces to experiment with
vegetable growth in Pittsburgh in the
city and then we've had a kind of
evolution of an idea of community action
with the community so in conversation we
have developed the idea of a bakery as a
commercial core to become a training
place for young adults to begin to gain
21st century skills so this is then
engaged many other fund applications we
seem to do nothing but write grant
applications the Fisher fund have
supported the furniture that goes into
our teaching bakery the people's gas
company have funded the artisanal oven
that will go into our bakery action
housing have stepped in to help us find
a building to rent and potentially buy
and the Hillman Foundation who have been
fantastic
are supporting the fit-out to that
building so all these complicated pieces
that are part of the power structure are
working in dialogue with the evolution
of the story with the community so we've
done a lot of work on the ground in
literally in the mud in a building in a
space that is totally derelict having
conversations because time is needed to
develop the ideas change happens slowly
we don't I'm British so I what do I know
Kristen has been living in friendship on
the borders of friendship and garfield
for about 50
and started an amazing community garden
called the octopus garden and that it
was from that garden that we then began
to talk about the idea of more complex
relationships between people why
couldn't there be a bicycle repair shop
and robot nee side-by-side so the really
far-reaching innovative and exciting
projects might be alongside things that
are very simple growing a few tomatoes
and in all of those things there are
beginnings to be connections for people
who don't have the access poverty is
concentrated barriers are there we are
trying to find ways of breaking through
those structural barriers and I think
through the conversations we have
decided that we should experiment with a
new way of teaching which is taking big
issues as well as very prosaic and
simple ideas in parallel so we're
developing a nine month training course
for young adults who might learn baking
skills kitchen safety all those things
but also might learn a lot about
themselves about society about how they
might be able to engage in a society
with greater power all the ideas about
sensing and being in charge of your
understanding is there available and if
we can use this paralleling of the
simplest activity with the most profound
and complex society that we live in we
have a chance of making some big change
so whilst you're kneading your bread
that's a place for conversation in the
complementary side of the training there
is a chance to write a poem think about
yourself understand where you sit in
society so there's an there's never a
kind of subject matter that becomes part
of the training that isn't complemented
by the larger idea ingredients come from
somewhere we have to understand how big
that subject is so that's the
educational idea that we're working
through and it's it's going to be
thrilling element of experimentation and
partnership that you talked about there
I think Wesley that also we see that in
your work in terms of the collaboration
that's involved in the experimentation
yeah so I was mentioning earlier that
part of my research is this evaluation
of gerrymandering and detecting actual
intentional gerrymandering that is
carefully drawing of district districts
for some political goal as opposed to
just some you know natural effect of
political geography so this here is the
congressional district of Pennsylvania
that was used since it was put in place
in 2011 so this is auditioning a
Pennsylvania into 18 districts and I
mean you notice all sorts of funny
things about it so of course there are
some districts with funny shapes there's
this red district in the bottom right
that is particularly unusual so if you
look at it just right it can look like
goofy kicking Donald Duck
but yeah so but that there are also you
know less immediately apparent things
that are quite remarkable about this
districting so in every election in
which this district has been used the
party that drew it so in this case the
Republican Party because they had
control the state legislature when the
decision was drawn has won 13 out of the
18 seats and and that happened even
years when Democrats won a majority of
the statewide congressional votes so for
example in 2012 Democrats won a majority
of the votes statewide in the
congressional elections but won only
five of the 18 seats so it's a really
remarkable districting and of course
that has led to the idea that this
districting and
possibly others may well have been drawn
intentionally to create this advantage
for the party that was the drew it and
and okay I mean when you look at this
district somehow that seems very natural
that's a suspect and I mean one
important question though is how we can
develop a rigorous way of evaluating
this and distinguishing intentional
drawing of districts like this from
things that just arise sort of by
accident because one thing that's not
obvious but it's true is that if you
just haphazardly district Pennsylvania
into eighteen districts you can easily
get a districting that favors the
Republicans by some margin just because
the political geography of Democrats and
Republicans are not the same right so
Democrats are clustered in in cities
much more actually than the Republicans
are dominant in rural areas so for
example the most democratic party part
of a state is always more Democrat or
almost always more Democrat than the
most Republican part of a state and so
in a collaboration with Alan Freeze and
other math professor here at CMU and
Maria chiquinha
who was at the University of Pittsburgh
in the computational biology department
there we developed a method and I'm
gonna start by just showing you the
mechanics of the method so in this video
which is playing now what you see
happening is a sequence of small random
changes being made to the districting so
voting precincts on the boundary of
districts are randomly chosen and then
the membership with that is which
district they belong to has changed and
so over time the districting is slowly
evolving right so you know if you if you
saw goofy kicking Donald up before
eventually Goofy's gonna lose his nose
here and then eventually his ears and
you know just slowly he's going to morph
into something else completely right and
no longer owned by Disney and and so the
point is right somehow what you're doing
is you're just messing with the lines in
these subtle ways and what you observe
when you do this is that very quickly
the districting is that you see have
less partisan advantage than the one
that you started with right so as you
start making these random changes the
parsing characteristics of the district
evaporates and I mean one way I like to
describe intuitively this result is the
idea that you know as you're making
these changes you can almost hear the
mapmakers in the back of your head
saying no don't
that's exactly that's exactly how I
wanted it right as soon as you make that
change it's going to be less favorable
to me and that's what you observe with
this algorithm yes I just like to sort
of get back to the franchise touch on it
for a moment because we in working with
our participants I've noticed how
difficult it is for the people we work
with to have an address and the
instability of the population we're
working with is mmm desperate really not
to know whether you're going to be able
to stay in your home or be homeless and
I think working with action housing
we've begun to realize the mechanisms
that are there in Pittsburgh to try and
stabilize a population which is at risk
particularly the kids who are coming out
of foster care system providing housing
for them and engaging in a workforce
development program then beginning to
match them to jobs and a career and some
stability but I wanted to also just talk
about the importance of data and how we
have benefited enormously from
collaboration with at various stages of
the ideas evolve the Katz School of
Business had nominated us as a capstone
project and the Executive MBA program
brought six people from all over the
world come to Pittsburgh to try and work
out how our business might work and were
able to interview every Baker in town
and write as a model to be able to
understand how we could be
self-sufficient through the profits from
the business paying for the education so
that was a kind of super important piece
of work and gave us a fabulous board
member who now helps us in each
evolution step of the game the moment
the computer science are now working
us to make an app for the trainees to be
able to do on-demand baking unlike uber
the trainees will be in charge of this
we've also been funded by Metro 21 to be
able to experiment with the use of
rainwater and the greenhouse production
so that there's a salad in the sandwich
lastly the kind of really important
moment that's happening now is as we're
doing syllabus writing we're making sure
that there is can feedback loop on our
teaching methods and we're being helped
to establish the evaluation methods for
the most ephemeral aspects as well as
the highly personal skill learning so we
want to be able to see a community
benefit from the bakery and the product
the activities of the students as well
and our presence on the street as well
as for the individuals who we will track
as they come into the the Nexus of night
our builder of our Baker's and grow out
into their careers not necessarily as
bakers so that's a kind of project that
they Robert Wood Johnson Foundation have
given us and funding to be able to be
helped to do that so as educators we're
kind of building our methodology and
hopefully then project little project in
Pittsburgh might have some applicability
in another city
not even with baking but with another
practical skill thank you and it's
really great that you're starting this
in Pittsburgh and a particular community
in Pittsburgh where it can really make a
difference I like to think about the
question of how these living labs can
really take advantage of what we have in
the city and why Pittsburgh is a great
place how about in your case how why
Pittsburgh if I think about doing smart
cities deployments and work along those
lines
pittsburg I think there's two reasons
you you'd basically struggle with one is
sort of the non-technical side of it and
one is the technical side of it so on
the technical side if you look at the
geography of Pittsburgh we have a lot of
bridges we have tunnels we have Hills
Pittsburghers don't like going through
tunnels it turns out neither do wireless
signals
it's basically where Wireless goes to
die so from that perspective there's a
lot of challenges we also have full
weather cycles so if you think about
anything geared towards environmental
studies or engineering we have real
winters we have real summers sometimes
they happen in the same day so it
becomes it becomes challenging it's not
just people working at CMU that see that
so for example uber came to Pittsburgh
they piloted their first autonomous
driving program here one of the reasons
they cited for that was if you know we
can build autonomous cars they can drive
in Pittsburgh they can basically drive
anywhere right especially in the US so
from the technical side and also there's
the mixing of old and new and the
infrastructure I believe we're one of
the few cities that actually has
multiple natural gas distribution lines
underground that they're trying to
connect together and largely it's
because of the history of the city so
lots of technical challenges on the
non-technical side really the fact that
Pittsburgh is a revitalized Rust Belt
City means that all of our local
government agencies and officials are
sensitive to the fact that technology
and education and medicine for example
have really bailed us out in or what is
causing Pittsburgh to be pretty glorious
and it's in its current day and because
of that we're seeing lots of industry
that's moving here so this is kind of a
technology map of Pittsburgh on the Left
compared to a photo of what it used to
be like as a steel mill city on the
right and it's not just kind of the
companies that are nearby that are of
course tightly collaborating with CMU
it's also starting to build a thriving
startup ecosystem and so Pittsburgh's
been cited as you know one of the best
places to do startups I've noticed lots
of my students now they all actually
want to stick around right they want to
stay in Pittsburgh they're not all going
to the Bay Area anymore and so I think
that's really indicative of
of a shift thank you in the case of our
living lab down the hall where we're
studying teaching and learning processes
I think for me the connection to
Pittsburgh is that you may not know it
but Pittsburgh Carnegie Mellon and the
other universities in the region are
really the home and the birthplace of
the field of learning science and just
as in all of our cases we're bringing
together multiple disciplines the
discipline of learning science combines
expertise in cognitive psychology social
psychology computer science artificial
intelligence all kinds of things to
bring these together and understand
learning in humans and how we can
improve that in fact herb Simon who was
one of our university faculty members
also a Carnegie Mellon Nobel laureate
was one of the founders of this field
and his work here has inspired a lot of
what Carnegie Mellon has done in this
space to really be thinking about the
science of learning but as herb always
said to make that part of our activity
in the university as well one thing that
herb is especially famous for saying
among my colleagues here is that
teaching should not be a solo sport but
rather we should bring the collaborative
and research skills that we bring to the
scholarly and creative parts of our work
to our teaching as well and so I think
that's really a great historical
Pittsburg foundation on which we build I
want to turn to my co-panelists and and
bring us to a close with a theme of
broader implications we've been talking
about some pretty exciting activities
and already seeing the impacts of those
maybe we'll hear a little bit more about
that Allah you gave us a little teaser
could you conclude your story and
broader implications with pleasure I
told you an air-quality story and the
challenge is to convey to you what does
that actually feel like for a
world-class university to reach into a
community at risk here now Eric
is a hyperlocal issue that's global but
everywhere you look it's hyperlocal
and what it looks like is two years of
staff PhD students masters students and
even volunteers from my classes that I
teach undergraduates driving to Ben Evan
and Avalon 40 minutes away every week to
go to the local community church
literally every week to meet with the
community members and do participatory
design of the kind that I've learned
from my inspirations at CMU it means
developing with them technology fluency
and data fluency and changing their
whole mindset about how they can have
impact and it means when that meeting
happened with the division coordinator
for the Environment Protection Agency it
means the community at the front using
our technology tools that we've
co-developed with them to show him the
layered evidence that demonstrates
without doubt the health impact on them
from the plant in this case the Koch
planted Chenango he stood up in the
middle of this and pointed at the screen
where I was showing a thousand five
hundred illegal plumes and said this is
not acceptable
two months later Neville island Chenango
was closed and then the Allegheny Kent
Health Department the same Department
that told us for 30 years we don't
really know how much of a health impact
this is having so we don't know how hard
to find them for 30 years they initiated
a study for a year to see what health
impact it had now that it closed and
that's when the Pittsburgh post-gazette
published what a month ago this paper
the Pittsburgh post-gazette
70,000 people live there and Carnegie
Mellon by creating technology fluency in
that group of people has decreased their
asthma entries by 38% cardiovascular
disease by 30% that's the impact that we
can have locally when Carnegie Mellon
does research that directly influences
the well-being of our own communities in
Pittsburgh and that community gives us a
pathway a structure a methodology that
we know any university should and ought
to apply to their own local communities
throughout the world so that's the kind
of evidence that I couldn't have dreamed
of in my 23 years I almost never get
that evidence because it takes multiple
and hard sweat to engage with the
community an impure relationship where
they actually become Co participants in
innovation and in community advocacy and
real change and that to me is a glimmer
of hope for how universities in general
can have a new kind of relationship with
communities that they're in yeah so I'm
gonna take us back to Pennsylvania
zooming out just a little bit so I I
mentioned that this was the
congressional district in Pennsylvania
since 2011 but now there's a new
district of Pennsylvania so this is the
next slide so this is now the
congressional district in Pennsylvania
that's because there was a lawsuit
brought by the League of Women Voters
against the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania
just this so just this past year so I
was an expert witness in this case the
trial was in December and then the
decisions came down in early 2018 and
the Pennsylvania Supreme Court ordered
the auditioning redrawn by a nonpartisan
outsider and right so the question is so
so I described this procedure before
that we use to evaluate a districting
and how can we make this procedures a
rigorous tool that can be used by a
court to reliably and rigorously tell
when a district was actually drawn with
intent and when it wasn't and so
remember I described this procedure
where we make these random changes and
we see that the partisanship of the
district evaporates and already that's
this strong intuitive evidence that
something was done on purpose right as
soon as you change the lines what you
know this partnership that was optimized
disappears but remember I described
before this interesting issue which is
that even a haphazardly drawn
districting one drawn without intent can
have an advantage for one political
party just because of political
geography so if your test for
gerrymandering was is the election
result surprising right that sounds like
a reasonable test at first glance but
it's not it's not a reasonable test for
establishing intent because a district
without drawn without intent
fail the test so the question you have
to ask when going to a court and saying
you can trust what we're saying is can
the test that you're proposing also give
you the wrong answer that is could a
district drawn without intent fail our
test is it possible that a typical
districting of an unusual state with
some unusual political geography that we
don't understand could tend to fail our
test so what we're asking there is could
it be that people are laid out in
Pennsylvania in such an unusual way that
when I take a typical district of the
state I get auditioning which not only
has a strong advantage for one political
party but has an advantage that
evaporates when I start making small
random changes to it okay and this
sounds like it's a question about where
people live in the state and remember I
said I'm from the math department so I
have no idea where people live in the
state we can ask these other people
where they live I don't know okay so
though the way we address that questions
from mathematics is that we proved a
theorem which says in a very general
setting so okay it's sort of stripping
out the technical terms the theorem says
that if I start with the typical object
in a very general sense a sequence of
random changes made to the typical
object will never tend to change the
object in a consistent way so if I start
with a truly typical thing random
changes of course can change the object
maybe I always get something different
but not in a consistent way which is
exactly what we saw with this district
districting right we start with a
districting we made a sequence of random
changes and the district got
consistently less favorable to the
political party that drew it and our
theorem then gives gives us a way of
quantifying exactly how unlikely that is
so we can tell the court the chance of
this happening for typical district in
Pennsylvania is one in 10,000 right we
can give rigorous quantifiable answers
to how likely this is to happen just by
accident in a way that then you can use
that to make a rigorous conclusion about
what you know and okay so let me turn
back tomorrow
[Music]
thank you these are really inspiring
stories about how the research and the
practice is having a real impact and
really making a difference in our
society I wanted to pick up on one final
theme that we've heard and it's sort of
the use of data and leveraging data for
good we are in a really exciting time
where data is available and we can
collect data for a variety of uses I
wanted to share a little bit about how
we see that data being powerful and
enhancing education here at CMU it turns
out our living lab down the hall is
unique among higher education teaching
centers to be able to instrument a
classroom like that and collect data on
the teaching and learning processes
here's just one scenario let's say you
are a new faculty member and you've
learned about this method active
learning you want to try it research
says it's really good for your students
but you've never used it before you're
not exactly sure if how you implement it
will really engage the students in your
class and help them learn better well
what you can do by coming to the
teaching and learning laboratory down
the hall is actually experiment with
that new technique with the support of
my colleagues around you but then get
the data in a very tight loop to to
learn how where your teaching moves
received we can measure things like the
students movement their effect can be
detected and show us something about
their engagement we can record pauses so
one thing that may naturally happen is a
faculty member may think they are giving
a lot of time for students active
involvement but we do have a tendency to
pontificate so this kind of data can be
really great feedback to us all as
faculty that actually Marcia you spoke
for 25 minutes straight or something
like that and this is what we want to do
for our faculty members
you are new to teaching for our faculty
members who are already expert and
they're taking that next leaf they're
creating the new teaching paradigms for
CMU students we want to give them the
data that can help them improve and even
enhance their learning and teaching also
we think these data sets and the the
inferences made from them could be
useful for students Farnum mentioned the
idea that we want to make the
educational experience more personalized
here at CMU and we really value the
power that this data could provide to
our own students so I'll just close with
a comment about how I see all of our
work really having an impact on humanity
and I like to think of teaching as one
of the most human of professions and see
how we can weave technology and research
state-of-the-art activities into our
work but really ultimately make a big
difference for our communities and the
region I think this has been so
wonderful thank you to our panelists
thank you to all of the audience members
for being here with us and with that I
will close this panel and ask you to
take a brief break and at promptly 2:45
that is after about 15 minutes we will
pick up again for our second symposium
of this great inauguration day thank you
all
you
[Applause]